let's see if we can solve the equation p
squared is equal to
0.81
so how could we think about this well
one thing we could do is we could say
look if p squared is equal to 0.81
another way of expressing this is that
well that means that p
is going to be equal to the positive or
negative square root of 0.81 remember if
we just wrote the square root symbol
here that means the principal root or
just the positive square root but here p
could be positive or negative because if
you square it if you square even a
negative number you're still going to
get a positive value so we can write
that p is equal to the plus or minus
square root of 0.81 which kind of helps
us it's another way of expressing the
same the same equation
but still what could p be
and your brain you might immediately say
well okay you know if if this was p
squared is equal to 81 i kind of know
what's going on because i know that 9
times 9 is equal to 81 or we could write
that 9 squared is equal to 81 or we
could write that 9 is equal to the
principal root of 81. these are all i
guess saying the same truth about the
universe but what about 0.81
well 0.81 has two digits behind the to
the right of the decimal and so if i
were to multiply something that has one
digit to the right of the decimal times
itself i'm going to have something with
two digits to the right of the decimal
and so what happens if i take instead of
9 squared what happens if i take a 0.9
squared let me try that out
0 let me do the different color so let's
say i took a 0.9
squared
0.9 squared well that's going to be 0.9
times 0.9 which is going to be equal to
well 9 times 9 is 81 and i have 1 2
numbers to the right of the decimal so
i'm going to have two numbers to the
right of the decimal in the product so 1
2.
so that indeed is equal to 0.81 in fact
we could write 0.81 as 0.9 squared so we
could write this we could write that p
is equal to the plus or minus the square
root of instead of writing 0.81 i could
write that as 0.9
squared in fact i could also write that
as negative 0.9 squared because if you
put a negative here and a negative here
it's still not going to change the value
negative times a negative is going to be
a positive i could actually i would have
put a negative there which would have
implied a negative here and a negative
there so either of those are going to be
true but it's going to work out for us
because we're taking the positive and
negative square root so this is going to
be
p
p is going to be equal to plus or minus
0.9
plus or minus 0.9 or we could write it
that p is equal to 0.9 or p could be
equal to negative 0.9 and you can verify
that you'd square either of these things
you get 0.81